Danny what did you do oh God they think
we're killing it we're not getting
tenders do they really expect me to
figure it all out in one season if
you're a contender you can't live in
this building we're being set up by
someone we know an overly quirky
collection of oddballs losers and
whatever the Seahawks are do we really
know any of them why am I podcasting so
much
interesting
next on the Bill Simmons our schedule
has been taking out the garbage I
already spoke to the authorities we
didn't do anything wrong sounds like
someone spread a nasty little rumor
about me again
they had to be close to us someone in
our division hey sorry still here do you
guys know how to get out
so it's either the Cowboys or the Eagles
it was me weird
he's an old man he doesn't know what
he's saying I'm just humble Jalen hurts
man are you
just think about it
Jalen hurts oh my people hurt people
fine sure I hit it in college but the
truth is I'm A Stone Cold killer arrest
me what what no man you just have to go
live with the good teams it's been too
long let's catch up foreign
I'm telling you celery is that nobody
believes in US vegetable of crudite
Brian Hoyer Ewing Theory candidate is
Shaggy from Scooby-Doo the cordarrell
Patterson of Hannah Barbera